أنه عندما بدأنا حياتنا
كان كل شيء على المحك في البداية لذا كان علينا أن نفتح الأبواب
لن يفتح حتى، لقد اعتدنا على فتح هذا الباب
أو لم ينس إلا لنا الباب
علينا أن نضرب الناس ونسيء معاملتهم.
ربما يتحدثون عنا بالسوء ولكن هذه هي وظيفتنا.
انه
وفي الوقت نفسه الصباح الجنسي للأمير ثعبان
وأكثر فعالية ليس فقط في باكستان بوصة و
إذا انتهى المعسكر الغربي، فعندئذ سأصاب بمرض شلل الأطفال
إذا أنقذتني من التغذية، أستطيع أن أعيش اليوم كله.
أنا مستعد لقضاء الليلة بأكملها بهذه الطريقة
قام المشرف ياداف بالبحث عن الفريق على المسرح
كانت هناك فوائد بسيطة لبيان الخيال.
يجب أن يكون تغيير الطريقة الآن مثل كبار السن للمحرك
كوني الممثل تشوك، هذا أنتم يا رفاق
مبروك يا رفاق سوف تأخذونا من هنا
لقد أتيتم يا رفاق لإخراجنا من هنا.
هؤلاء الفتيات من Nidhi يعملن بسبب هذه الدراجة.
ولكن عندما يذهبون، يتم ذكرهم أكثر.
وكان علي أن أتحقق من هذه أيضًا، ثم قمت بذلك
كان راي يقف عند كل محطة في الشارع.
أنه حتى الفتيات لم يعودوا
لذلك أنا أيضا لم أعود.
وببطء ببطء لهم
لقد حصلنا أيضًا على آلام في المعدة وهؤلاء الأشخاص
كما بدأت التسوية معنا
ذلك منذ أن بدأنا الحمد لله
احصل على نوم أقل وأكثر
أريد أن أرى هذه المنطقة لأن
لدي أطفال باكستانيون.
البعض يريد أن يصبح مهندسا والبعض يريد أن يصبح طبيبا.
شخص ما يريد أن يصبح جنديا، يريد أن يصبح جنديا.
لقد تولت باكستان المسؤولية عن هذا السقوط العادي
أنا أضع كل قلبي وعقلي وأموالي فيه.
أنا
اخبرني المزيد!
افعلها
نهب